William Rodríguez era Sembrador de coca
de niño acompañaba a su padre a los
cultivos yo era pequeño y yo andaba por
ahí
en la coca
pero yo no sabía raspar eso pero desde
hace dos años llegó a este municipio al
Oriente de Colombia para sembrar cacao
en un plan de sustitución de cultivos
apoyado por el gobierno colombiano y que
fue implementado tras el acuerdo de paz
de 2016 con la guerrilla de las FARC que
se acabaron en el cultivo y cambiaron
por cacao hice también reciben plata
por eso es mejor que coca mejor que coca
es el cacao toneladas de cacao en
viernes de la región en aviones de la
fuerza aérea entregan el producto a una
empresa chocolatera de la capital Bogotá
la empresa paga de los agricultores unos
dos dólares por kilo junto con los
pueblos de chupabe y Puerto Príncipe la
zona era conocida como el Triángulo de
la coca pero ahora todo ha cambiado y
utilizan ese nombre como marca comercial
de los chocolates que producen que
siembra cacao primero que debe estar
contribuyendo con la paz con una
estabilidad legal está haciendo útil a
un país que ha vivido en tanto tiempo en
guerra
y le está cambiando la imagen a una
región de esta que fue tan aporreada tan
lastimada por los grupos ilegales unos
800 agricultores unieron sus fuerzas
para plantar 240 hectáreas de cacao en
esta región pero a pesar de los
esfuerzos por cambiar los cultivos
Colombia Aún es el mayor productor de
cocaína del mundo con 204.000 hectáreas
plantadas en 2021 aún hay esperanza de
cambio las exportaciones de cacao siguen
en aumento a países como México y a
continentes como Asia y Europa